the head coach of the atlanta falcons
always enjoyed our chats in the uh
non-playing season as we like to call it
as he's getting ready for his first
campaign as head coach of the atlanta
falcons now 4-4 heading to dallas for a
big week 10 game fresh off a big dub in
new orleans on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is arthur smith head coach of
the atlanta falcons how you doing coach
great rich how you doing i'm doing uh
i'm doing just fine thanks for calling
in i appreciate it mid-season i know
that uh that not a lot of coaches do
that so i greatly do appreciate the
phone call um we we heard about you know
the cowboys last week and what uh what
the broncos were able to do to them and
you know we hear people saying yeah just
bury the tape cowboy should just bury
the tape what does the uh upcoming
opposing coach do with that tape arthur
smith well i think you look at the
entire body of work
the cowboys in my opinion they have one
of the more talented rosters in the
league
um there's a reason they're six and two
they got playmakers all over the field
on offensive defense so we got a heck of
a challenge on sunday but we're excited
about going down there so there is stuff
obviously for you to pick up from
something that uh everybody says the
other team should bury
clearly right for you well it's not
necessarily works like that i mean i
mean the pinnacle is tough i mean it's
always safe
if you want to live for the week-to-week
narratives i mean it'll eat you alive
and you just gotta take the body of work
um
things happen in the game and the way
the momentum shifts
you know turnovers or non-turnovers that
you think are turnovers like on the punt
you know all those things
it all there's all there's a cause and
effect every game so
um
you know credit to denver but we know
that the dallas cowboys to me are one of
the more premier teams in this league
and we're excited about going down there
arthur smith head coach of the atlanta
falcons here on the rich eisen show um
and ever since cordaro patterson came
out of college coach the words
associated with him were upside
potential that you clearly clearly have
tapped into in a way that he has not had
it tapped into in previous stops when
did you
first have this idea that cordell
cordero could do it all essentially for
your team
well really when we signed so we had a
vision for them and there's stuff that
we practiced
with them in the spring and as you know
we go those packages during camp they
look pretty good and
absolutely we're really vanilla in the
preseason trying to build the depth of
the roster and
you know as we then
in the regular season um
you know it really was down in tampa
that it started to take shape and
and then obviously what we know
the way that game in the fourth quarter
was ugly but
we knew that it was it was gonna break
through and uh he made some big plays in
that giants game and then
the washington game here uh you know he
kind of went off and and your god the
natural is uh
arthur come on arthur don't don't defeat
him
excuse me excuse me he may feed the
animals it's his zoo right here come on
now you made this week coach you you
really did you really did use it in the
form of a sentence too coach my gosh
that's great did you did you bring it up
to him did you bring it up to him yeah i
mean that's what you know and i think
he's running with it so he's got to get
it on his cleats
[Laughter]
that's what he said right after he found
cordero towards the end of the game
against the saints he went up top and
then that was a huge play for you that
that that that got uh your kicker out on
the field for the winner he screamed at
you i'm the matchel right that's what he
did pounded pretty much it was loud in
there but that pretty much saw the same
thing you did you just kind of you know
you're lip-reading whatever yeah i'm
pretty sure that's what i heard
oh man i love uh when guests give me
what i want you know it's just it's
terrific there is an iron rich in eyes
and i am a team player but uh i love it
i i do i do love seeing that stuff man
and so
how how
how has this been part of your vision
what
uh ryan up top to to patterson right
like this is what you're you're trying
to draw up in big-time moments of
big-time games and seeing it in front of
you against the saints how how does that
propel your team in your estimation
coach well like all right guys when we
have a really unselfish team uh he said
we're you know we're right in the middle
of it and it's where you want to be you
want to be playing meaningful games in
the middle of november or early november
as you get into december and so
um
you know we're
we're good with where we're at you know
we feel like we can play a lot better
and we need to
uh but very pleased i mean this is a fun
group to coach
uh we've had guys step up in big moments
i don't think there's a kind of better
clutch kicker in the league this year
than young away coup uh we've had
different guys make plays and big
moments so
very pleased and hopefully we just keep
improving
arthur smith here uh on the rich eisen
show and so uh
kyle pitts and his development where
where can he get better in your
estimation
so far
yeah there's a lot of places um mike
what you know kyle's got the right
mindset i mean just the little nuances
of route running uh you know and he's
he's such a quick learner and then you
know those guys make the transition into
the nfl i mean they quickly realized
that everybody's fast in the nfl
and these guys there's some really smart
players and smart coaches on the other
side and
you know it's a week to week and
it it's probably what i think surprises
rookies is that the mental challenge to
prepare yourself week to week
that that can what can exhaust some guys
and that's what you're trying to fight
that fatigue but with kyle like he's
he's really really mature for just
turning 21. and all the little nuances
he picks up on pretty quick he's made
some really big uh plays for us and
critical moments and i think he's just
scratching the surface can you give me
an example of the nuance or the
preparation you know earlier this is how
you know you're playing versus man and
how you want to create separation in
your rock craft with your releases or
your second level releases when you're
in the middle part or how you're going
to lean guys to set them up and and to
have a stem and then have something off
it
um
and that's why he's able to win on the
outside when he gets pressed that's why
he's able to win in the middle of the
numbers whether he's running a crossing
route or an outbreaking route
and he's getting open and then
and making key plays and sometimes in
college if you're just bigger and faster
you just run by people but everybody's
fast here they know they study your
route tree
um
but he's come up big whether he's in
miami he's had big moments in just about
every game
how about force feeding him in the red
zone more uh coach how about how about
making sure more time you can try that
and and you know if you want to be uh
obvious and let people take take people
away but we got a lot of people that
score i mean there's a reason that
olamide is the kiss it's got three
touchdowns because we don't we preach
unselfish play and they uh
it may make some fantasy football uh
gm's you know angry at me but uh that's
the way we played in tennessee and then
some guys naturally you know they take
take over but
very pleased i mean when they one guy
draws attention you better be able to go
somewhere else otherwise you got no plan
they can take you away
i hear you but um uh uh kyle pitts
yes i do coach i'm just walking through
the front door i'm walking through the
front door yes yes i do well at least
you're transparent so
yeah you know i'm just a little bit more
a little bit more um in the end zone is
all i'm asking for you know uh because
he could he's got that ability he can
high point it he can as you say you know
create the space he can he could do all
sorts of stuff like that i'm just trying
to talk his game up to the coach
no i hear you okay thank you i greatly
appreciate that arthur smith here
on on the rich eisen show um so uh
turning uh to a much more serious issue
um
calvin ridley coach and how how do you
um
handle
a player saying to you
i need a break i need to step away right
now how do you and i guess handle is the
wrong word for it how do you welcome
that how does that sound for a better
way to phrase it because handle is a
much more
um
it's infused with something that's
negative and i think uh obviously him
requiring the time is positive um and
i'm just wondering how you take that in
as a coach in your first players we have
we care about all every every person we
have in this building that works and
this on this football
staff is a part of this team
uh from the equipment room to the video
room to the players the coaches and
everybody that
that is part of this team and so i think
what you're realizing
now is you know i think in football
everybody can see visible injuries and i
think as we realize in society
um certainly you know things have come
to light you know what it was covered in
the things that have gone on
uh with mental health or you know you
look at the veterans and you know coming
out of 20 years of warfare there's a lot
of the invisible injuries are
that they're serious and and anybody
that needs help with anything that you
know whether it's a
they said visible injury or invisible
injury we'll do everything we can to
help
and so what what is i guess the plan for
for calvin did you just wait for him to
say those things
rich you know like everybody you know i
don't
disclose people's injuries as their
personal uh you know the players can
speak calvin put out a statement that
you know he wanted to put out there and
i'll let that stand i'll let calvin
speak for calvin just like i would for
any player on this team if they want to
talk about they have a knee injury
they that's that's their prerogative to
talk about it but that's i'm it's not
gonna come from me
let the talk about their own personal
um
you know anything they got going on of
course no and i totally understand that
my my question is do you wait for him to
say i'm ready and and you just go about
your business otherwise
that's that's
you know the way you look at it big
picture there's always things
um with every player and you can't you
know what people need like i said i take
it back to every any injury anybody has
or something comes up and there's a life
event
um
you know there's there's a lot of guys
on this roster we've got a lot of guys
that
have
different guys that played week to week
and we don't force anything uh we
wouldn't force anybody back from any
any kind of injury so
we take it you know day by day or week
by week and
and that's how we we view it so there's
no timetable on it and um and nor would
i push anybody on that arthur smith here
uh on the rich eisen show last couple
minutes with you coach uh is there
anything in the first eight weeks
that uh part of your job that was
something um
unexpected something that um you were
ready for because you
kind of focused on it anything over the
first
two months of the season
that you you can share about being at hc
for the first time in the nfl
well you prepare yourself i think when
you you come into the office every day
you
said you there's nothing going to come
up and if you think every day is going
to be perfect and
in the wrong profession or you're just
naive um
and so you try to prepare yourself for
it and you try not to overreact because
there's plenty of things that come up
day to day
um we have a good group here we have a
great staff so
the other thing is just kind of focusing
in the biggest challenge that's all is
not to live
and die by the by the week to week or
day to day narratives because if you do
that
it could be ugly for people players and
coaches and so
everything i feel like everything i've
done
not skipping any steps been around some
great coaches it's helped me prepare for
this okay so drown people like me out is
that the message that you're giving to
your your team coach i mean i mean i
wouldn't call it drowning out it's just
you know you take the entertainment for
what it's worth
is it uh is it something you pointed out
to your team uh watching the braves do
what they do and seeing what a parade
looks like in in your town anything like
that there's come up there's lessons
learned i mean like i whether you know a
couple years ago i told the story
where i was um
i had two nephews at
the naval academy one was graduating so
i was in annapolis for a weekend i go to
the nationals game this is in 19 i
believe
they weekend and you know i go to
they're sitting there saying they need
to
you know trade all their pitchers away
build for the future and then they were
a couple months later won in the world
series i think you kind of saw the same
thing with the braves it happens in
sports over and over it kind of goes
back to the point of like
living and dying with the day-to-day
uh short-term narratives all right and
then uh i know it's another team but uh
in your division did you hear the news
that cam newton is back in your division
that the panthers signed him that's good
no it's good for the panthers good for
cam it's good for the nfl okay so every
week there's there's no challenges
there's great players uh we got our
big challenges this week and that's kind
of what we're focused on is dallas and
we got our hands full like i said it's
probably one of the more talented
rosters in the league
we gotta go on the road
and a meaningful game here in november
appreciate the time say hi to the
natural for me and i appreciate you
natural you said hello appreciate you
using a form of sentence like that you
really have made my day and you have
angered the rest of everybody around
here well that's okay you do you you do
you coach thanks for the call all right
appreciate it thank you yeah that's
arthur smith everybody head coach of the
atlanta falcons you do you sir
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here